pues ahora es que no sabemos qué es lo
que puede ocurrir se rusia también
tomará medidas frente a otros países
europeos y también les cortará el gas de
momento hungría ha asegurado que el gas
sigue fluyendo en su caso porque llegó a
un acuerdo en que podría pagar en euros
y así luego poderlo convertir en rublos
los pagos del gas pero la decisión ahora
mismo podría redoblar la presión a las
capitales europeas que actualmente están
negociando un posible embargo del
petróleo y del gas pero es una cuestión
muy divisiva hay países como por ejemplo
precisamente hungría que lo están
evitando que están bloqueando esta
decisión pero no es casualidad que rusia
haya tomado esta decisión sabe que es
una cuestión muy decisiva y podría
dividir muchísimo más a los países que
hasta ahora ha mostrado una gran unidad
frente a las sanciones el frente a las
sanciones contra rusia hay que tener en
cuenta que aún así la comisión europea
propuso reducir dos tercios este mismo
año la dependencia del gas ruso pérez no
será nada fácil y como ya se comentaba
la inflación puede subir y también los
precios